Anthony Peeples: We have between 800
and 1,000 Funko Pops, give or take.
I'm Anthony Peeples.
I'm a Funko Pop Collector.
I'm feeling high-five fantastic,
and I hope you are as well.
Narrator: Funko Pops are everywhere.
They're those small plastic figurines
with giant heads and big round eyes.
There are pops of pretty much
every character you can think of.
And fans are obsessed.
The company did half a billion dollars
in sales in 2017.
And has already surpassed that in 2018.
Anthony, who goes by the
nickname GeekyPeeples,
has taken his obsession to another level.
Peeples: Funko Funatics is
definitely a common term
that we all use to refer to ourselves.
Narrator: Anthony and his partner, Raul,
have been collecting Pops since 2015.
And they can be found all over their home.
Peeples: They're displayed
in all the various places
that we can find room in our
New York City apartment.
We have one room that is our room that
we've kind of transformed into a Pop den.
My DC wall is dedicated to
"Batman the Animated Series,"
which was very important to me
in my childhood growing up.
I'm a big Marvel boy,
so I collect a lot of the Marvel lines.
I have one wall dedicated to Freddy Funko,
the Funko mascot.
The other wall is kind of,
"storage."
It's a slow process so
I'm building the room up.
Narrator: His kitchen is decorated
with Pops that are food related.
Peeples: A friend of mine,
he actually displays his
Mr. Freeze Pops in the freezer.
Narrator: And when we visited in October,
his living room was decorated
with Halloween-related Pops.
Peeples: So all of the
Pops that are horror based,
or fun, or scary.
And we also have Pops
displayed in our bedroom.
Narrator: Anthony keeps track of his Pops
using several online apps.
Which estimate that his collection
could be worth thousands of dollars,
based on market value.
But the prices can change over time.
His first Pop was a Storm figurine
given to him as a gift from friends.
Peeples: And then from there,
it just took fire in side of me
and I just wanted to
collect as many as I can.
I actually still have that Storm,
it's right there on the wall.
I keep it right where I can always see it.
Narrator: His collection
includes many rare Pops
that were released as limited editions.
Including some ultra rare ones
called Chase Pops.
Peeples: A Chase Pop is
a Pop that you can find,
kind of like the golden ticket
that Willy Wonka was giving out.
It's very rare, and there's only
a certain limited amount of them.
And they also have a
special sticker on them.
Also, if you collect comics,
it's like a variant cover.
Narrator: In 2017, he
went to the grand opening
of the Funko Headquarters in Washington.
And got his hands on one of
his most prized figurines.
Peeples: It's the Emerald Freddy.
It has the flagship sticker on it,
which was also very rare.
I also have another very rare Pop.
The blue chrome Batman
from San Diego Comic Con.
I slept for four days
in front of the San Diego Convention,
and I ended up getting into the booth.
I cried a lot because I was so happy
and so excited.
The chrome Batman is worth a lot of money.
I've seen it go up right now, currently,
as high on Ebay as $800.
Narrator: He and his partner also placed
in a lipsyncing contest at a Funko Event.
And chose two giant Robin
and Joker Pops as prizes,
that he estimates are now
worth about $1,200 each.
Peeples: I do also have just
a couple rare Proto Pops.
Narrator: These are basically
prototypes of Pops before
they're massed produced.
Anthony doesn't just
collect Pops, however,
he also organizes events
with fellow collectors,
including fundraisers for charity.
Peeples: I host here in
New York, periodically,
events that I call Peeples Pop!Swap.
Those events have been
major, major moments
where I've gotten to
meet so many collectors
and have so many wonderful friends
because of that.
Narrator: In addition to swapping,
Anthony often sells Pops
to help fund his trips
to various conventions around
the world to buy new ones.
Peeples: Cause it's very expensive.
The expenses do mount up.
Narrator: He's active in
the official Funko Forum,
a message board for fans.
So he always knows where to be
to get the rare Pops for cheap.
Peeples: I try to get them as close to
the retail value that they come out for.
Narrator: But he will occasionally
have to pay upwards of $100 for some
that he missed to complete his set.
He has a few basic tips for Funko hunters.
Peeples: So it's best
to just be on your game.
Know your information.
Know where the Pop is you want.
Know how much it's going to cost.
And be prepared to line up
and hopefully score some
wonderful Funko Pops.
Narrator: And he says he has no desire
to stop collecting anytime soon.
Peeples: Whether I
collect Funko Pops or not,
the one thing that is a constant,
is that the people I've met
and the relationships I've established
from being in the Funko Pop community,
they're not going anywhere in my heart.
I will keep in contact whether
I collect Funkos or not.
And there's a story behind each one.
Some people identify
themselves as "I'm a fiend!"
and they'll be wearing the fiend patch.
Or they're a Funkero.
There's Jersey Funko and
there's Chicago Funko.
So many across the country
and they identify themselves in that way.
But we're all Funatics,
we're all Funko Funatics.